I have not seen you since the Hunger
Games came out congratulations on that
you did a great job playing you want an
MTV Award Effie that's pretty cool it
was really fun mostly because I got to
dry-hump Channing Tatum
who gave me the award and Matthew
McConaughey what they came out and David
Award and this happens when a TV they
came out to and to give out the category
and what was really funny is uh they go
to announce it and I wasn't sure if I
was winning and and they started playing
this music and Johnny Depp was also
nominated in my category sounds like
they started playing music I thought Oh
Johnny Depp want it and then Joe
Manganiello from True Blood he plays a
wolf and mostly he's just shirtless yeah
yeah that's how you would know him he's
a shirtless whoa it's shirtless all the
time he came out cuz they were promoting
Magic Mike then I had Matthew
McConaughey Channing Tatum and a
shirtless Joe Manganiello on stage
handing me a golden popcorn and I
couldn't pass it up I just took my
chances with all three of them I just
made it clear that my intentions were
not pure so you were were you was there
contact was oh yeah there was full
physical contact there was some there
was some maneuvering of the popcorn in a
direction like this
me I think by McConaughey he'd be the
one to do that sounds like McConaughey
that's his thing so that's crazy now
what you I know you're married was your
husband in the audience he was there for
sure
uh-huh okay what's his reaction to all
this you know he like like your wife I'm
sure is it's not not caring because
you're asexual
now he you know he's like I guess it's
just sort of you know I'm flirty it's
the way of the world here in showbiz
yeah I mean honestly I felt like if he
had a chance to just hang out with like
Jennifer Lopez he would try and and
smack that baby you guys have a very
healthy relationship even together yeah
this is the key right so he so he's not
threatened like if you and I were to and
I'm not saying we should but that's kind
of the balls in your court now but if we
were to like start rubbing up against
each other hey hey whoa that's fantastic
yeah your husband's right heading yes
uh-huh
sure some of this
Wow well I'm glad that he has a good you
know he's a good cuz you guys know each
other long a long time you guys met in
college my husband at 20 we just
celebrated 20 years of being a couple
okay
[Applause]